hikaru an inspiring uh performance in
the blitz section nevertheless i see you
a bit disappointed describe to us uh
your feelings right now i'm disappointed
i mean i could hardly be happier
honestly i mean i didn't show for three
days and then i at least tried to
remember how to play chess the last two
days so
um i mean with the way alireza played
throughout the tournament obviously very
deserving winner um and in particular i
mean the way that he played today at
least or it was never realistic like i
can look at my tournament and be unhappy
about maybe two of the games in the
rapid and i think i should have drawn
instead of losing but it still wouldn't
have made a difference so it's really
hard to be unhappy um you know i think
i'm actually quite happy with the way i
played after these two uh these two
unfortunate losses today and just just
won a couple games to the end so yeah
second place pretty good when did you
feel like you're regaining your mojo at
the beginning of the blitz section which
one was the precise moment i mean
probably it was well i think for the
blitz it was the first two games both
days i mean yesterday i had the two
whites and i kind of after this game
against fabiano which i lost in the rap
but i just wanted to play chess there's
really nothing else in my head at that
time at that moment um
and i won that game i won against eleven
the rest of the day kind of flowed today
was i mean much different i i i felt
like i probably should have made a draw
against alireza in this third round game
after the second game which was really
um a very tilting loss that i had
against lavon but i figured okay
i should probably try um and obviously
that didn't go well but then i was able
to stabilize pretty quickly in the
following game against uh sam i think it
was so overall i mean i can't really be
that unhappy i wish i had played better
in the rapid but i don't think that the
overall result was in doubt so after
being in last three days to finish in
second
can't be better really couldn't ask for
more hikari you have a legion of fans
behind you any words for them and what's
next for you um well i mean i think i
showed i could play chess i think a lot
of people after three days were saying i
should like go back into retirement or
things like this especially my good good
friends over on that famous reddit uh
right at that subreddit so um yeah i
mean uh in terms of upcoming tournaments
i don't have a lot i actually felt that
probably it was a big mistake that i
didn't really get any time off before
playing here i mean i played this rapid
chess championship which was four days
in a row um against other top players
then i played this like 960 title
tuesday rainy kings i mean i played
seven days in a row before this event
and i think that was uh probably too
much overall uh
and then moving forward um
i mean i go back to streaming
next tournament that i know i'm playing
is a 960 here in st louis in a couple of
weeks and then probably uh there's this
tata steel event at the end of november
i believe it isn't if there's a world
wrapping but it's probably that but yeah
a couple of tournaments but i get to go
back to my real job so it's all good
congratulations hikaru always a pleasure
to have you here in st louis thank you
our congratulations as well hikaru and
let's take a look